lot of that I'm Lara TT I'm Ranma dalla
on the meet River nightmare of dreams
yeah yeah this isn't traumatizing at all
this river of meat
a river of meat it's a delicious and
tasty treat hey hello everybody my name
is markiplier and I think I've already
lost my mind to this game but it we've
always scratched the surface on what
could possibly be the weirdest game I've
ever played floating along my Mead river
on my paddle Oh which is basically a
duck but either way I got the rest of
the code so I think I can quickly solve
this puzzle and get on my way and it
shouldn't cause any more trouble for me
so the code is four nine eight two six
five seven oh come on no that was it no
that was you can't lie to me that was it
okay four nine eight two six ah fudge
the slapping sounds with the delicious
meat ah you lied to me oh you lied to me
you lied to me you lied your lighting is
this done it's done did I do it did I
did it I think I did it I think I didn't
I can go back to the beginning where it
would be unlocked now I think the blocks
that were blocking off the front
entrance are probably gone now so let's
go down there and see what other horrors
this zone of nightmares can give me hey
before I do that I get to see these
weird guys
yay all done at birth Aries purified I
got a luck ticket continue on the meet
River nightmare of Green River Ness I
don't know I don't even know what I'm
talking about anymore
okay go save huh this game sure has
interesting puzzles not that they're to
Tara blue this place looks nice
I wonder what awaits me in this zone god
no Oh looks exactly the same
oh hello how you doing I wish you good
day omnipresent comrade you will soon be
able to admire all the apples and
ultramarine landscape of this area you
seemed bewildered by the unique
architecture of this place if that is
the case you should learn to concentrate
in order to not be misled whilst
choosing the opportunities offered at
each corner of the maze you had better
oh it's a maze remain and ponder a
little while longer before crossing one
of these trap doors next time young
drunkard
I'm not even recording that okay was
that the advice that you meant to give
me that doesn't tell me anything you cat
bastard bye all good well I'm glad that
happened
oh hello have I lost that I lose damn it
wait a minute if I went left the first
time it didn't give me back here so
maybe maybe this is the loo screen
ah so am I supposed to go ah so it's
left up let me just write this down so I
have an idea of exactly where I'm
supposed to go left up this might be a
long thing of trial and error Yeah right
good very good about down nope that was
bad how about flummox
ah not you whoa what are you I don't
even want to know what I'm gonna kill
you as quick as I can yeah your dad let
me throw another curveball and go right
oh it's another right whoopty Fripp they
do what about a left up poopie this is
gonna take a while let's go take a long
damn while
all the music gets louder before I have
to go the right way I got it okay so
yeah ah I got it I got it I'm smarter
than the game I got it oh yeah I'm
writing him down just in case anyway but
oh oh who's smart who's smart I'm
actually guessing the right directions
oh no good thing I wrote it down
Oh what the hell no no no wait a minute
what what's going on wait wait well what
happened huh no what oh well I did it
how did I did it what did i do I didn't
think that I did it what the hell
happened I what okay all right then
I don't get it I don't know what I did
but I did it so there am I about to
fight a boss am I sure that I want to
pass through this gate pretty sure where
else am I gonna go
hey you sir you are the Queen's Thousand
Faces that's a pretty queen
are you crazy are you just completely
[ __ ] what part of I'm going to kill
you didn't you understand I'm here to
eliminate you you're insane
I have the guardian of Zone one it ain't
nothing without me
what mare's disorder got your blind
faith to heart even the slightest bit of
evident from your valve I'm the one
who's going to purify the world and
you're the pest that eats away at this
land
prepare yourself why did everyone get a
British accent you're going down no Otto
for you you'll taste the pain you sick
spirit Oh
your face to remove this insufferable
smile no no God ever no no no that's
right that's right I'm doing this all
mano a mano him some on that yeah get
down to tell you bad self
you're one ugly sack of crap I can see
your nipples so weird
don't you even tried I'm Way too strong
for you well you think I'm just been
training up on everybody for no reason
you are going to crap hell hey we almost
heard a little bit but not really oh
yeah I'm Hannah's going easily when I
can do these competence attacks oops
yeah how much more healthy I've left I
think I can analyze them and let me
analyze them that's probably gonna help
whoa what do you oh come on not gonna
tell me any what's the point of that
Shack anyway
Howie I've heard a lot okay hang on I'm
gonna there's another thing here that
can yeah I like that yes yes I'm getting
it I'm getting it I'm gonna do that
again get full health I'm good at games
I'm good at these games okay this time
you going down okay how much health you
think you have left oh [ __ ] I didn't
mean to do that again but oh well I
guess getting up to fourth now
yeah I got it that guy doesn't seem to
be focused too much on onion-ring Larry
onion-ring Oliver whatever his name is
does that mean get out of here yeah
that's right don't even think about
talking to me think I'm doing this right
God is he gonna die soon how much health
does this guy have
why is he way way way more over than the
other guys you're right then just keep
slapping them no you don't know it's
that talky I don't even know if that
does but I'm gonna kill it
get out of here open the curse for how
you're dying and in pain so yeah no no
no no
oh now you're attacking my other game
how much help do you have just get out
just fall over fall over Oh God
aah objects server flesh uh oh no no no
wrong person represent well it's not
going well okay you need more result you
need silver flesh to restore your yeah
there we go
and now we're doing it now we're doing
it now we're doing it yeah you do that
oh [ __ ] he's asleep oh I have something
I can cure that
ah the Lyle's me yeah yeah yeah yeah
awake now confidence courage there we go
you need to go back on the offensive
before this guy kills me Oh Manzano not
keep getting it to the batter I mean
appreciate god you're so nice but stop
it huh now give CP to the batter there
we go
batters gonna save first base for you
there we go
now we're doing it now back on the
offensive but that's right yeah suck
that down tack tank how much house do
you hang okay
hmm stop hitting my little guy he's
barely barely holding it together this
is hard to do when you don't have
anything to do although you actually
gotta concentrate on what your choices
are okay yes yes yes come on hit hit hit
hard hit hard
come on oh my god I'm actually
interested in what's gonna happen no no
no you get that out of here get that out
of there yeah no not the batter again
yeah
damn it you son of a [ __ ] say eleven
Helen Hill hill mob Dix there we go
that's more like there we go god I gotta
get get out of here stop it
just die already yeah I can't believe
I'm that excited about it but yes
suck on that 3000 XP 601 credits cancer
card batter level six anyway furious
homerun that that sounds like a great
thing alpha level six yeah is this a
joke I lost loser lost yes you did
you've been defeated date done guardian
of the first zone this land is now pure
I don't know if I ever finished
purifying the smoke mines but hey what
can you do so long as this guy goes away
that's all that matters
yes I would like to save let me slave in
block two because this seems like it's
going to get interesting
Oh what the hell is that hello is that a
goat it's that tiny goat creature oh
it's a baby
dot dot dot that started badly what did
what sorted badly oh god I bet the
nothingness again guess I can go to Zone
two
now I could the whispering has started
what the hell is the room I want to go
to the room the room let's just soak in
the atmosphere a little bit really get a
feel for this room of nightmares
there's nothing mr. exists in between my
mind days I'll do oh it's pink and
delightful my favorite yes please do
I wonder what weirdness awaits me in
this land
oh it's delightful give everything I've
big mustaches
oh ah how nice cinematic Zone two I like
it
show me more I really do like this game
a lot guys I really do appreciate it
this game is weird in all the right ways
and that last game was actually quite
stressful
Bismark Center library or lower part are
these zones different dimensions or not
or they do interact in some way I think
ah well then are you trying to tell me
something mm what are these symbols mean
we go in the library and find out it's
not easy to file your way out here
having looks the same why do you live in
this weird place these shelves are fake
are there any real shelves here mr.
badda bodda these shelves are fake yes
you shouldn't lend any more books to
that man he turns out the pages it's
almost dangerous yes I'm going back
upstairs okay bye have a fun time in the
library give me a buck come on rip out
the pages hello welcome to the ladder I
should point out that the upper floors
are inaccessible because of the specters
they're specters in this building Hey
yes why do you ask I will eliminate
I'm single-minded like that it eliminate
the specters but you know you can get
had and there's nothing for you up there
just wall shelves stairs and an old cat
a cat I'll go up the stairs I'll go up
and purify the upper floors oh good okay
don't beat you out then and the fourth
floor is really not access is really not
really not really accessible people have
torn out pages of the book so I don't
want to go up there it could be
dangerous
okay what does that mean what do you
care what do you mean you do nothing
wrong
Hey what's going on here huh huh what's
up with this wall then huh what's up
with this wall you trying to tell me
something by the wall mmm
I don't like it oh wait a minute what so
it's different area it's different parts
of the libraries that were the same this
is a large building good congratulations
ah ah the east entrance of the library
so each of them obviously is part of the
same place hello I'm upstairs now
don't turn the pages it makes too much
noise okay I'll make as much damn bloody
hell noise as I want to make oh god no
oh god is there most stuff that laughter
I'd hang on I gotta get a piece of paper
so for cheese she chose three guardians
to rule some of the zones the Firebird
was chosen as the lord of the second
zone the eternal city of bismarck blah
blah gibberish to 44 into 40 yeah [ __ ]
oh I can't read this hang on maybe I can
and go so sharing in the belly of the
world 700,000 something are not our Arne
of the do not at the justice put in
place by the Queen
during her peaceful reign they are the
physical way station of evil deed
released what is that clicking sound as
annoying physical UN fist a ssin of evil
deed released upon the world and forever
lost in their seething I can sort it's
weird the faster I go the more I can
read it seething madness they are
unsalvageable and in immortal only the
Queen Regent the time of the final
confrontation will have the power to
annihilate talent power of the world
work child Chapter two oh my god this
Sora oh my god huh Oh children of the
upside down of children um no not it
right okay so only the real ones are
here okay arcus a FLIR 152 and 153
goddamn was there even any point of me
trying to read that toad King a long
time ago lived an evil King his face was
so repulsive that he was nicknamed the
dode King one day a masked man met the
king during an audience he said two of
the falling words to him greetings
wretched monarch leave this land at once
or perish at the tip of my blade the
king replied I am The King and you are
my subject you are not to go against my
will and so the masked man slew the king
with his mighty sword the end what the
hell
alright then sixteen sounding oh great
story there everybody glad I read that
cardinal points oh I see
um is a Bugaboo I know if that was is
for the thing yeah seems it no matter
how much I try the book stays upside
down there's no title on the cover I
have run out of oxygen okay then oxygen
away explanations I would like that
Oh fine Oh two no three oh I don't know
what any of those B's what are you doing
I prefer the fake books you don't need
to worry about damaging them written by
es 126 126 92 and 93 friends in guard
Madame vous Cummings's Oh Crozier it's
gross dear assist it's in French I can't
read this
whatever can someone please translate
that for me thank you
so I need that it so 1607 is the other
one okay wrote it down don't know if
it's gonna help me at all but there we
go I've got all the numbers maybe not
all the numbers hello there's a book
with a page missing um looks like a four
why is it a form but 32 okay am I gonna
do anything four of diamonds am I gonna
do anything with all these numbers that
I'm running down is there any reason for
me to do this I found a joker good for
me I am utterly confused there's a page
of a book on the wall weed ah
the three of clubs gone three of clubs
and it says 33 good so are all these
books part of another book because that
seems to be this thing ah the Ace of
Spades Ace of Spades
and it says 32 again what the hell is
going on here I have no idea what's
happening I don't know if anything that
I'm collecting is important oh my god
Queen of Spades of kids and it's 33 okay
whoopty-doo top oh good I was waiting
for you know you're upside out good
Bing bong dead dong don't you slap me
you silly Billy I'm gonna furious home
run you punk there you go you're dead
you were very interesting to fight you
lost me a dance moment I could have
danced I just wanted to dance it's a
buck with a babe missing oh god the two
clubs two clubs
alrighty then and this says the club's
not spades thirty-two okay five of
diamonds thirty-three okay so these are
paint these are paired up okay so that
was the diamond so if I go back to the
diamond book and put it back in is that
gonna help me out pretty sure that's the
way it's gonna go
it's our page good good good yeah I did
it what does that do no idea the spades
don't make any sense cuz they're the
wrong age oh seven of Hearts good for me
that slapping needs to stop okay
Gogi this is actually gonna take a while
so I'm gonna come back when I've solved
the puzzle and tell you how he did it
afterwards thank you okay so so far I've
put all the pages back with their
accompanying suits but what I haven't
been able to do is I haven't been able
to get the other heart piece I've gotten
the spades clubs and the Diamonds
together but not the heart so I need to
figure out where that would be so
there's got to be some other areas out
there oh no no okay how do I come closer
wait a minute what you have a page
well that's oddly convenient what kind
of page what what kind of page did you
give me h 33 oh whoa why are those there
why are those all but hey the heart that
was exactly what I needed exactly when I
needed it
um okay I'm not gonna question why er
how but it may I have it so that's all
the matters and that is oddly specific
when I just need it exactly that I swear
I'm not cheating guys I just happen that
way I didn't do I didn't do it okay
whatever
so insert the pays and that should be it
right cool
what is that am I done that I did it
it's possible the man oh I should talk
with the receptionist ah
I put the pages back in order everybody
maybe you're gonna let me through the
gum floor hello there lovely reservist I
put the bait back in that douche bag
that was ripping the pages out I gave
him the old what for a hundred of the
one for us I let you up then that's
great the fourth wall is now accessible
for you and you only okay good but you
said it was infested with specters do I
get to hit them with my bat repeatedly
and they blood back to juice everywhere
also known as ectoplasm all over the
place thank you for healing me I needed
that now I'm gonna continue in brain
some more Spectre goons are there any
long necks oh hello
another no no you're different you're
different you're different you're not
the same yeah that's what I thought
who are you what is that in your hand
you're not the judge let the judge know
and now I'm not my name is jeff' it I am
the creator of the city I'm also one
leading the Phantoms
the royal instruments of my vengeance
you're the chief of the spectres
specifically they are my arms sent to me
by the Queen to restore justice to this
zone you must have been very determined
to set foot on to the stairs of this
library I recognize in you or certain
courage an exceptional trait for a fear
riddled blazer disease however my
revenge will not leave anyone unpunished
this hurts my cheeks thus you shall be
the first to come to the blasts of my
ectoplasmic army is that an innuendo oh
I don't want to get ectoplasmic e-blast
I do not need any spectres yet to
eliminate you you bought sport
pajama-wearing clown hi I make fun of my
pajamas I'm not even wearing pants I
will validly dated you know blah blah
blah blah blah I'm gonna smash your face
pop boom boom hey special attacks your
spirit is a valid one and your arms are
made in its image I must confess that I
may have underestimated you
unfortunately few I would discard all
manners as a gentleman when necessary
especially for a new and
beca's come to me dance together a
nickel the songs of the righteous the
torment of men heals my wounds
your body will feed the intangible
spirits for eternity
phantoms Panem's come to me to gaseous
automatic baleful human do you manage to
prevent Maya - plasma calculus from
joining me no matter you will taste my
mouth oh it's awesome I thought that's
it Oh are we
goodness gravy don't do that well if
that's how you're gonna be I need to
heal back up oh that does not heal very
much bonk hey I did it I killed him
purify that can't a purified the purse
can the only 300 experienced hundred
fifty Chris a batons mean I haven't even
done IV other weird a baton Hey huh it's
not your time to be to reveal by true
danger still know that you will gain
nothing by waiting obnoxious much River
wait a minute what the hey wait a minute
what are you doing up there
onion ring oh oh oh I got AB and Omega
now hey hey what does that do for me
this barrier prevents me from going
upstairs it's impossible to climb any
higher at this point well then I guess I
go back home now I guess I'm all done
here and I never need to come back ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
again still don't know what's going on
at least I got a new buddy buddy to join
me yeah I got a new buddy I got onion
ring Orville and then I got a ring uh
Oliver onion ring Oliver an O ring
Orville that's what I got that's what I
got right now could even get hurt up
there well honey raid I saw a cat expect
it to be by the south entrance maybe
that's my cat maybe that's my cat now
hello that is market greetings dear
immaculate comrade as your journey not
taking you to a place of optimum
conditions this is a drier area compared
to the previous surroundings
I must admit that I for one am delighted
the feline gent is not very fond of rain
I have heard from an old friend of the
shopping mall in the northern part of
the city has fallen victim to
ectoplasmic assaults but absent would be
wise for you to hurry on over there an
eliminated with your purifying light
well alright then Thank You mr. kitty
cat you are always a good shining
example of what humanity or whatever the
hell people live in this place have to
offer the world so I'm in the northern
part ah the shop the mall is full of
specters it's terribly frightening well
if you say so I don't know if I believe
you
hello mr. sharp a man hang on I need to
get equipment for my other guy I have
two rings now yay
when is the s misty amok Blair wears
better place to shop than a shopping
mall that all fortune ticket it's about
time I start getting something a little
bit better all right so the masu I'm
definitely gonna get myself a better bat
hell yeah no no no don't need that okay
so I need okay a loyal symbol so I need
two of these oh my god not ten of those
for those I need I don't know if those
are gonna be better than the ones I got
but hey those look pretty nice bonk get
those defensive equipments up color of
pain color of sadness why would I need
those that sounds horrifying okay I need
two of these ah I think I already have a
David tunic unless it's a different
tunic either way I need at least one
more of
eze oh and wait it says what I have okay
so I need that then I need two of these
not should do me I'm pretty much all out
and then I can actually start selling
stuff hang on a second okay
persistent symbol call Erickson that's
not much of an upgrade but hey I guess
is leasing something or a fear ulna
epidermis colour of sadness no special
okay okay versus oh I already have it
wait loll symbol that's right
oh that was the one oh okay wait a
minute then did I do that right did I do
that wrong of sadness works yeah okay
that was it got it got it got it sorry
sorry sorry difference okay that's good
so they should be about the same I think
yeah wait no what huh what rises sub-17
nope that's about the same okay here we
go
ooh big upgrade my favorite David tuna
glance hmm I like it so much so now I
can sell all this crap hey give me this
stuff get out of here ah long all those
clerks and we're gone Justin's gone
Harold back gone radius epidermis gone
I'll do some gone full of rats gone that
didn't give me a lot I'm not gonna be
able to get a lot of food back but hey
maybe I don't need it we got it here
ready to go all right okay so that'll
about do it for this episode I'm not
sure if this is gonna be shorter than
the other ones just because there was a
lot of running around the background but
you guys might thank me for that not
showing you the boringness of me going
back and forth over and over again
didn't miss anything important so thank
you all so much for watching I am
thoroughly enjoying this so far I don't
even know why it's got me so intrigued
my curiosity is like in the red I want
to know so badly and I don't even know
if it's gonna let me know so either way
I really hope you guys are enjoying this
if you are please click the like button
down below
and let me know in the comments thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye and suffering to
the rainforest